tu m'inviteras un jour à sortir on
attendra juste le bon moment
sortir avec quelqu'un d'autre pour le
reste de ma vie je n'aimerai
personne d'autre pour le reste de ma vie
j'attends le bon moment parce que
quand je t'ai demandé de sortir ça va être le
moment le plus important de ma vie et je
viens  je veux m'assurer que je fais bien les choses
Oh la
vie nous trompe elle nous induit en erreur il
peint un homme est un héros alors qu'il peut bien
être un méchant héros ou un méchant mais un méchant
ou un héros bien que j'étais dans mon peut être
les héros et les méchants  de nos histoires ne
sont en fait que des joueurs de jour et un
film beaucoup plus grand mais j'étais des rêves nus et
je veux vivre une grande grande vie fantastique
marions-nous nous sortons ensemble depuis moins
d'un an je sais et j'ai l'impression d'avoir
montré  une retenue incroyable en attendant aussi
longtemps, vous pouvez
[Musique]
Je t'aime, je ne suis peut-être pas équipé pour  être
autant
aimée ne le prends pas mal tout ce que j'ai toujours
voulu était de vouloir épouser une femme
dont les parents sont décédés afin de ne pas partager les
petits-enfants impliqués c'est bon elle
sait
[Musique]
loi si étrange moment complètement aléatoire
qui s'est produit bien avant  Je suis né mais
j'ai façonné toute ma vie
es-tu content que ce soit arrivé commence petit
grandisse hé es-tu enceinte étoile
petit monde hein
[Musique]
toi